GREG GUTFELD, DANA PERINO AND
KIMBERLY GUILFOYLE AND THIS IS
"THE FIVE."
IT'S AN ALL-OUT WAR OVER
IMPEACHMENT THE WHITE HOUSE
TELLING DEMOCRATS TO TAKE A HIKE
BECAUSE THEY WILL NOT COMPLY
WITH THE RIGS IN QUERY.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS CALLING OUT
THE DEMOCRATS TACTICS AND THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER.
>> THEY HAVE EVISCERATED THE
RULES.
THEY HAVE A MAN NAME ADAM SCHIFF
A PERFECT PHONE CALL, WITH
UKRAINE, AND I MEAN PERFECT, AND
PEOPLE READ IT, BUT THEY DON'T
READ THAT, THEY HEARD HIS
VERSION OF IT BUT HE DEFRAUDED
THE AMERICAN PUBLIC, SO A
DEMOCRAT, IT A STRONG DEMOCRAT
WORKING WITH ONE OF MY OPPONENTS
AS A DEMOCRAT THAT I MIGHT END
UP RUNNING AGAINST.
THE WHOLE THING IS A SCAM.
IT IS A FIX.
>> Jesse: THIS COMES AS
JOE BIDEN FOR THE FIRST TIME
BACKING IMPEACHMENT.
>> HE'S ALREADY CONVICTED
HIMSELF.
IN FULL VIEW OF THE WORLD AND
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE,
DONALD TRUMP HAS VIOLATED HIS
OATH OF OFFICE, BETRAYED THIS
NATION, AND COMMITTED
IMPEACHABLE ACTS.
TO PRESERVE OUR CONSTITUTION,
OUR DEMOCRACY, OUR BASIC
INTEGRITY, HE SHOULD BE
IMPEACHED.
>> Jesse: BIDEN'S WORDS
SETTING UP A TWITTER BATTLE WITH
THE PRESIDENT, AND DONALD TRUMP
RESPONDING THIS WAY.
SO PATHETIC TO SEE SLEEPY
JOE BIDEN AND HIS SON HUNTER
INTO THE DETRIMENT OF THE
AMERICAN TAXPAYER HAS RIPPED OFF
AT LEAST TWO COUNTRIES FOR
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS CALLING FOR
MY IMPEACHMENT.
AND I DID NOTHING WRONG.
JOE'S FAILING CAMPAIGN GIVES HIM
NO OTHER CHOICE.
AND JOE BIDEN HITTING BACK,
THANKS FOR WATCHING.
HONOR YOUR OATH, RESPECT THE
CONSTITUTION AND SPEAKING OF
TAXPAYERS, I HAVE RELEASED 21
YEARS OF MY TAX RETURNS, YOU?
ALL RIGHT, A LOT OF STUFF TODAY.
BEFORE WE GET TO THIS WHOLE DEAL
WITH THIS IMPEACHMENT, LOT, LOT
OF BREAKING NEWS ON THE FRONT
AND ON UKRAINE FRONT THAT MAY BE
TO ADDRESS SOME OF THESE.
NEW DOCUMENTS SHOW HUNTER BIDEN
NOT JUST PAID $50,000 A MONTH,
RECORDS SHOW $156,000 A MONTH.
$166,000 A MONTH, WOW, A LOT OF
MONEY.
ALSO, THE UNITED STATES NEW
UKRAINE OPENING UP AN
INVESTIGATION INTO BIDEN'S IN
FEBRUARY SO THAT DESTROYS QUID
PRO QUO AND ALSO THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER A DEMOCRAT AND
WORKS WITH SOMEONE RUNNING
AGAINST PRESIDENT TRUMP ALSO A
DEMOCRAT.
USED TO WORK FOR JAMES CLAPPER
SO RESPOND TO ANY OF THOSE.
>> Juan: IN OTHER WORDS THE
PRESIDENT WAS PRESSURING THE
PRESIDENT OF UKRAINE EVEN THOUGH
UKRAINE STARTED AN
INVESTIGATION?
JESSE IT MAKES NO SENSE.
>> Jesse: I AGREE.
>> Juan: WHERE IS THE QUID PRO
QUO?
HE DIDN'T KNOW WHAT HE WAS
DOING.
NO, LOOK I THINK THE FIRST THING
TO ADDRESSES THIS LETTER THAT
CAME OUT YESTERDAY AND THE
CONTINUAL STONEWALLING BY THE
PRESIDENT AND THE WHITE HOUSE.
THIS IS DANGEROUS.
THIS IS A CONSTITUTIONAL CRISIS.
HE'S TRYING TO BREAK THE SYSTEM
OF OUR GOVERNMENT.
CONGRESS HAS THE RIGHT TO
IMPEACH AND INQUIRE AS TO
WHETHER IMPEACH A PRESIDENT AND
HE SAYING I'M NOT COOPERATING
AND I'M NOT GOING ALONG.
THEN HE ATTACKS THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER.
THE WHISTLE-BLOWER IS A
DEMOCRAT.
EVERYTHING THE WHISTLE-BLOWER
HAS SAID IS COOPERATED AND GUESS
WHO COOPERATED IT?
DONALD TRUMP.
TRUMP RIGHT NOW IS SPENDING I
THINK THIS WEEK ALREADY $700,000
ON ADS.
HE SAID, WELL, IMMIGRATION
STIRRED UP DEBATE SO I WILL STIR
UP THE TALK OF IMPEACHMENT.
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT STRIKES ME,
MITCH McCONNELL IS PLAYING
ALONG AND OTHERS OF THE COUP.
THIS IS AN ATTEMPT TO REVERSE
THE 2016 ELECTION.
THIS IS ABSURD.
THIS IS A CONSTITUTIONAL CRISIS
IN WHICH A PRESIDENT IS ACTING
AS AN OUTLAW.
AN OUTLAW.
>> Jesse: AND OUTLAW, WOW.
>> Juan: I LOVE WHEN DEMOCRATS
SAY HE WAS TO BREAK THE
FOUNDATION OF GOVERNMENT BUT
THEN WHEN YOU CALL FOR
NANCY PELOSI TO ACTUALLY
TAKE A BOW AND HELD
ACCOUNTABLE, YOU GUYS GET
PROCEDURE.
YOU CAN'T SELECTIVELY CARE ABOUT
APPROPRIATE PROCEDURE.
BUT THEY CAME OUT AND SAID, THE
WHITE HOUSE ONCE A VOTE TO BE
HELD AND THE DEMOCRATS AND
REPUBLICANS TO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THAT DECISION.
THIS IS A SERIOUS MATTER, AT THE
FULL TRANSCRIPT OF THE
DEPOSITION AND THEY ARE SAYING
IF YOU ARE GOING TO DO THIS YOU
HAVE TO DO IT PROPERLY.
I GET JOE BIDEN NEEDS THIS
REALLY BADLY TO BE A HEADLINE.
HE NEEDS THE TOP OF EVERYBODY'S
PAGE, IMPEACHMENT, IMPEACHMENT,
IMPEACHMENT BECAUSE HE DOESN'T
WANT YOU TALKING ABOUT THE
ECONOMY.
HE DOESN'T WANT YOU TALKING
ABOUT BORDER SECURITY.
HE DOESN'T WANT THEIR
ACCOMPLISHMENTS THIS PRESIDENT
HAS PUT FORWARD TO BE
HIGHLIGHTED AND HE DOESN'T WANT
HIGHLIGHTED HE HASN'T SET FORTH
AN AGENDA AND MOST DEMOCRATS
CAN'T NAME THE POSITIVE THINGS
HE WOULD DO IF HE ACTUALLY GOT
ELECTED.
SO HE NEEDS THIS STORY BADLY.
UNFORTUNATELY FOR HIM, HE'S ON
TAPE DOING THE EXACT QUID PRO
QUO STUFF HE'S BLAMING
PRESIDENT TRUMP FOR DOING SO YOU
KNOW WHAT HOLD IMPEACHMENT
HEARING AND LET BIDEN TESTIFY.
>> Jesse: AND A GREAT TACTIC
TO SAY, SHOVE IT, DEMOCRATS,
LET'S GO TO COURT.
DO YOU WANT TO ABUSE YOUR
AUTHORITY AND EXECUTIVE BRANCH,
YOU KNOW WHAT I WILL SEE YOU IN
COURT.
DRAG IT OUT PAST THE NEW YEAR
AND ERODES THE ATTENTION OF
DEMOCRATS TO RUN FOR PRESIDENT.
>> Dana: I THINK THERE IS NOT
A CONSTITUTIONAL CRISIS BECAUSE
THERE IS A SYSTEM IN PLACE AND
EVERYBODY GETS TO USE THE
SYSTEM.
REMEMBER WE HAVE BEEN HEARING
CONSTITUTIONAL CRISIS SINCE
BEFORE THE ELECTION EVEN TOOK
PLACE.
SO THAT WEARS A LITTLE BIT THIN.
PRESIDENT TRUMP RELISHES A FIGHT
SO MUCH HE WEARS DOWN HIS
OPPONENTS.
THE THING FOR BIDEN, HE CAME OUT
WITH A LITTLE BIT MORE FORCEFUL
BUT NOT A PURE MESSENGER ON
THIS.
HE DOESN'T HAVE A SPOKESPERSON
WHO IS ABLE TO DO IT FOR HIM.
SO THERE IS NO, LIKE HE IS THE
VICE PRESIDENT.
AND IT GETS BACK TO OBAMA GOING
AFTER GEORGE W. BUSH FOR TORTURE
ALL THOSE TIMES.
WHO CAME OUT AND DEFENDED?
IT WAS DICK CHENEY, RIGHT?
THAT WAS THE PROPER PLACE FOR
DICK CHENEY TO BE TO BE ABLE TO
DEFEND.
VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN WAS THE
VICE PRESIDENT AND ALSO NOW THE
FATHER OF SOMEBODY ACCUSER,
ALLEGATIONS AND I DIDN'T KNOW
$10
$16,166,000, THAT IS GETTING UP
THERE.
THAT IS A LOT.
BUT HE DOES NOT HAVE AN
EFFECTIVE MESSAGE OUTSIDE OF
HIMSELF AND NO ECHO CHAMBER AND
THE DEMOCRATS SAYING IMPEACHMENT
BUT NO ONE DEEPENING THE ACTUAL
ALLEGATIONS.
SO I DON'T KNOW IF HE NEEDS RUD
RUDY.
>> Jesse: EVERYBODY NEEDS A
AND ACTUALLY THE DNC NOT COMING
TO HIS DEFENSE HARD ENOUGH BUT
LET'S LISTEN TO DONALD TRUMP'S
NEW SOUND ON JOE BIDEN AND THEN
YOU CAN REACT.
>> President Trump: BIDEN IS
DROPPING LIKE A ROCK.
I DIDN'T THINK HE WAS GOING TO
MAKE IT AND I DIDN'T THINK HE
WAS GOING TO MAKE IT FOR A LONG
TIME.
I DIDN'T THINK HE WAS GOING TO
MAKE IT.
HE DIDN'T SAY THAT UNTIL RIGHT
NOW.
HE SEES WHAT'S HAPPENING TO HIM.
HE'S NO LONGER THE FRONT RUNNER.
HE'S BEEN HIT AND CAUGHT
RED-HANDED.
>> Greg: WELL, YOU KNOW I
DON'T BELIEVE THIS IS ABOUT
ACTUAL IMPEACHMENT, RIGHT?
WHAT THEY ARE TRYING TO DO IS
CREATE A QUAGMIRE PROCESS, OKAY?
SO THAT THEY CAN WARP PUBLIC
OPINION AND SHAKE THE CONFIDENCE
OF REPUBLICANS WHO SUPPORT THE
PRESIDENT WHICH IS HAPPENING, I
THINK.
HANDICAP HIM WITH A HOLE, BIG
GIANT CLOUD HEADED FOR 2020.
THE REASON WHY THEY ARE DOING
THIS IS NOT, IT IS BECAUSE THEY
HATE HIM.
BECAUSE, DO THIS LITTLE, DO THIS
LITTLE EXPERIMENT.
I BROKE THE STEP DOWN A SWEAR
WORD.
IMAGINE A DEMOCRATIC PRESIDENT
DOING THIS IN THREE YEARS.
USHERING IN PRISON REFORM,
DEMOCRATIC PRESIDENT DRAWING
DOWN WARS BECAUSE HE'S STINGY
ABOUT BLOOD AND TREASURE.
USHERING IN RECORD EMPLOYMENT
FOR WOMEN AND MINORITIES,
GROWING MEDIUM HOUSE HOLD TO A
RECORD $66,000, PLACING
RESTRICTIONS ON CHINA FOR
SUPPRESSING MUSLIMS.
THAT SOUNDS LIKE THE GREATEST
DEMOCRATIC PRESIDENT IN HISTORY.
DEFINITELY BETTER THAN OBAMA.
HE JUST HAPPENS TO BE A
REPUBLICAN.
AND HE JUST HAPPENS TO BE
DONALD TRUMP.
SO IT'S ALL ABOUT HOW MUCH THEY
HATE THE GUY BECAUSE THEY SHOULD
BE EMBRACING HIS POLICIES.
I AM AMAZED HOW MANY DEMOCRATS
ARE UPSET ABOUT THIS DECISION
WHEN BASICALLY, IT IS ALWAYS
BEEN ABOUT AMERICAN TROOPS
FIRST.
MAKING SURE THEY ARE SAFE, NOT
RISKING BLOOD AND TREASURE.
SO THE THING FOR ME IS LIKE, IT
DRIVES ME CRAZY THAT WE PICK
THIS STORY, SERIOUSLY.
I'M NOT JUST A FOX HOST, DANA
BUT A VIEWER.
YOU KNOW THE GUY AT THE HAIR
CLUB COME I'M NOT JUST PRESIDENT
BUT I'M A CLIENT.
I'M A FOX NEWS CLIENT SO IT
DRIVES ME NUTS THAT WE TAKE
SERIOUSLY THIS NARRATIVE, THIS
CONJOINT NARRATIVE FROM THE
DEMOCRATS AND THE MEDIA.
CNN AND "NEW YORK TIMES,"
"WASHINGTON POST," THEY MUST BE
LAUGHING THEIR OFF TO THEIR
ATTENTION.
THIS IS SUCH A JOKE.
SUCH A JOKE AND ALL DESIGN TO
WIN AND ELECTION.
THAT IS ALL IT IS.
>> Juan: I WANT TO SAY THIS.
>> Greg: DON'T YOU THINK THE
GREATEST PRESIDENT EVER IS
DONALD TRUMP?
>> Juan: HE SWITCHED PARTIES
AGAIN?
>> Greg: YOU CAN'T DENY
ANYTHING I SAID.
>> Juan: YES I CAN.
>> Greg: PRISON REFORM,
ECONOMY, SYRIA?
>> Juan: WHAT ABOUT THE COAL
MINES?
>> Greg: WHAT ABOUT THE COAL
MINERS?
>> Juan: HE DOESN'T CARE ABOUT
THE COAL MINERS.
HERE IS THE THING.
>> Greg: HE IS A THREAT TO
YOU, THE MEDIA, THE DEMOCRATS,
THE RICHEST SKUNK IN THE GARDEN
PARTY AND NO ONE KNOWS HOW TO
GET HIM OUT OF THEY ARE.
>> Juan: YOU ARE A FOX VIEWER
YOU SAY.
>> Greg: I SHOW THROW THE SHOE
AT FOX BUT ONLY WHEN YOU ARE
TALKING.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Juan: NAPOLITANO SAID YOU
CAN'T SAY TWO PEOPLE IGNORE WHAT
YOU CAN SEE FOR YOURSELF WITH
YOUR OWN EYES.
>> Greg: EXACTLY THE
TRANSCRIPT.
>> Juan: THE PRESIDENT WHO
RELEASE LETTER SAID BASICALLY I
WAS USING AMERICAN MILITARY AID
TO EXTORT A FOREIGN COUNTRY.
>> Greg: YOU JUST PULLED IN